i don't know if there's a bigger name to
robert kiyosaki and a lot of people
respect robert kiyosaki i respect robert
kiyosaki okay
uh we were just with him at pbd's
birthday the other day and i had a word
with him i've interviewed kiyosaki he's
the only person
that would not say my catchphrase he's
the only person
that would not say
save that money he goes no no i'm not
saying it and i'll tell you why and he
went on a rant about the zimbabwe dollar
and inflation and i get it for him but
here's the latest with robert kiyosaki
have you heard about what he's been
predicting
in october this is our first show in
november so we you know we could have
had a show maybe right before halloween
but now this is our first show in
november and everything that he's been
predicting that would happen in october
you know what happened it happened
didn't happen oh robbie
robert hughes hockey anyway here's the
story and we'll get it and i want you
guys to give me your honest feedback if
you think i'm right i want you to say
sas you're right on this one bro or sas
you done messed up bro you just came at
the king robert kiyosaki
you just came with the crown no
stay in your lane buddy
call me out if that's something but
here's what's going on here's what
robert kiyosaki did and let's talk money
right here so basically rich dad poor
dad aka rich dad robert kiyosaki has
basically been predicting a giant stock
market crash in october he came and said
look it's happening stock market crash
october mark my words bet on it it's
going to happen he did this at the end
of september so
robert kiyosaki predicts a crash it
doesn't say a crash is coming soon a
crash is coming this year he says in
october
you know alarm bells should should
basically go up you should say okay does
what does kiyosaki know that i don't
know what does kusaki know that the
financial experts out there aren't
predicting cnbc bloomberg they're not
predicting this but kiyosaki is right
okay
so basically it started with this he
tweeted this this is the end of
september beginning of october kiyosaki
made this prediction he tweeted giant
stock market crash coming in october why
and he lists these reasons treasury and
fed short on t bills
gold silver bitcoin may crash two
cash best for picking up bargains after
a crash not selling gold silver bitcoin
yet have lots of cash for life after
stock market crash stocks dangerous
be careful so that's what
robert kiyosaki came out tweeted you
know what put
his reputation put himself
out there on the line and you know what
david what's up well now it's november i
don't know how close you fall the stock
market these days stock market just
reached all-time high i was going to say
a complete opposite yeah so no giant
crash so it's got me thinking kiyosaki
what's going on here the new tom zenner
the new content
what's going on here so
you know i interviewed kiyosaki he's
been talking about bitcoin gold and
silver for months years now
and i actually asked him this was once
pat's birthday october 18th so he
probably had a party mid late month
right right right around his birthdays
you know two weeks ago i said
into his face
kiyosaki what's up how you doing you
remember me yes i remember you we did an
interview yeah you wouldn't say save
that money yeah i still say don't save
that money okay cool hey kiyosaki
um you you predicted a stock market
crash
in october
where you at with this right now again
this was two weeks ago he goes no no no
i i it's gonna happen and maybe maybe
more of a bond market crash
but you know i'm still sticking to my
guns
here's the problem i got right now
maybe the bond market isn't exactly
doing great but who gives a [ __ ] about
the bond market especially if you're
young you shouldn't be investing in
bonds stock market index funds etfs
target date funds how much do you love
index funds david i can't get enough you
can't get enough of index funds i can't
get enough of index funds okay
401ks roth ira raise all-time highs
right now meanwhile kiyosaki's basically
predicting a crash what is going on
kiyosaki
bobby i don't know what's happening so i
asked him i said kiyosaki what's going
on he goes well you know so here's my
prediction here's what's going on
sometimes when you're
the man
and maybe you're not in the headlines
anymore and there's maybe younger people
coming up you want to make some
headlines yeah and he came out and put
his reputation online and basically
predicted this crash why say october
why put yourself like why put your
reputation online and say it's happening
biggest stock market crash ever october
it's november stock markets all-time
high at what point do you think kiyosaki
bro what's the credibility here like
that's what i was going to do i would
never to his face disrespect him i got
first personal finance book i ever read
financial book was rich dad poor dad
okay i've interviewed the guy i've had
respect for the guy
but we do have different philosophies
let me break this down right here he
says
again
um
cash best for picking up bargains after
a crash okay
uh have lots of cash for life after the
stock market the problem is this do you
know how one acquires cash
how one acquires cash yeah the atm yeah
i mean yeah they save that money yeah
they they they get their paycheck they
make money and they save it sure okay so
rob this is the car argument that i had
with the kiyosaki he says don't save
that money we crazy he encourages a lot
of people he's a big real estate guy so
you got it's also one of those things
like where are you getting your advice
if you're into real estate and you're
and you're into you know commercial
properties and taking on debt taking on
mortgages taking on loans kiyosaki's
probably got some sick advice for you
but if you're one of those people that's
like look
i don't like debt i don't want to take
on debt i don't want to put on more risk
i want to save that money i want to be
investing in the stock market
kiyosaki's basically does not stand for
that at all right but he's sort of
contradicting to himself so it's bad
it's the fact that he's saying have a
lot of cash on hand this is the same guy
that's basically saying [ __ ] cash take
on debt and
put your money into real estate so it's
kind of like he's having it both sides
so this is going to seem like i'm
disrespecting kiyosaki there's going to
be people we know how you know youtube
trolls who are you to complain
talk trash about kiyosaki you ain't [ __ ]
buddy right i hear you i'm not on
kiyosaki's level right now that's true i
got a long way to go
but at some point
when someone makes an incorrect
prediction or puts their name on the
line and it doesn't happen
are you allowed to
you know
i think call them out
on them being wrong is that is this the
first is this the first time that this
has happened where he's predicted
something and it's been opposite i mean
because you can be like okay well you
know we miscalculated give the guy a
break
fair enough
but the flip side whether men are wrong
all the time it's literally other men
are wrong every
every other day
but my point is this kiyosaki knows what
he's talking about he ain't no fool he
ain't no dummy
why come out and say this why come out
and put your reputation online i've been
following the stock market all of us i'm
not that i'm never not following the
stock market all of october basically
thinking okay here it comes it's coming
it's coming kiyosaki crash where is it
the q what bitcoin all-time high stock
market all-time high i mean everything
crypto all-time high she knew ebu
whatever the freaking uh you know
enoshibu whatever the hell that stock
ethereum all-time high bitcoin
shiba whatever
um we're going to get into that in the
crypto corner but at some point it's
like kiyosaki you were wrong bro
maybe i want a retraction maybe i want
him to say hey guys
i was wrong maybe that's what i want i
don't know if he's going to go it's
november 4th maybe he he'll get to that
but i think you know
i don't know
you guys let me know in the comments am
i out of pocket here right now
do you guys trust kiyosaki's advice here
if there's a stock market crash what are
you guys going to do about it i want to
know what's going on let me read the
rest of the story okay again i am all
about save that money to invest in the
stock market that's my entire strategy
business model i don't own real estate i
don't own property if i'm going to
invest in real estate i invest in reits
why because i can't like to keep my
overhead low right and my flexibility
high i like to keep it moving i like to
keep it grooving i like to rent every
few years when i get make more money and
have more money in the stock market and
invest more i'm moving to a nicer place
now keep in mind i don't have a mortgage
i don't have a wife i don't have kids
it'll happen someday david i pbd says
he'll pay for my wedding if i get
married in the next three years
you have to get married now yeah this
free would save that money free wedding
i mean hello save that money by the way
i've done that before it doesn't work
out well um
but kiyosaki as much respect as i have
for him he's kind of wrong i stand on
the opposite side yes i mean obviously
he was wrong but if kiyosaki predicts
something i'm not not gonna listen
i'm just saying
and then you could go into is this
personal is this like a personal if you
want to go down that rabbit hole as did
he try and say it was gonna crash or
people would sell and then things would
i don't know but here here's some more
quotes from from kiyosaki and let's make
this about our friends at home i see i
see people listening i see people
commenting i see people saying that sas
you're right i trust you i see people
saying hey buddy shut your stupid face
you got nothing over kiyosaki cool i
respect you on that i said on the onset
of this kiyosaki is way more established
than me i'm not trying to say that i'm
on his level i'm just calling a spade a
spade here here's the deal couple
kiyosaki quotes he also shared this the
primary reason i invest in bitcoin gold
and silver is because i do not
trust our leaders the fed the treasury
nor the stock market unfortunately mom
and pop who save money do he does have a
point there i would not trust our
leaders to make big grand decisions with
your life this is why you need to have
financial independence not rely on the
government not rely on social security
not rely on savings rates or anything
like that that's why you gotta
reach financial independence listening
to advice like this he says i like
crashes a crash is good
the crash is a good time to get rich i
feel you so that's why i'm very
optimistic on gold silver and bitcoin
not on stocks okay
well let's see where bitcoin is as as of
today so he is a fan of bitcoin
huge fan of bitcoin oh for some reason i
was under the impression he wasn't here
i can pull it up here
bitcoin is at 61.61 000.
now if you go back and you check where
bitcoin was one month ago
it was at
42 000 a little over four so not only
did it not crash
it's gone up exponentially
all i'm saying is cue socks so what's my
point here
what happened right there
tell your point okay listen
it's always important to put things in
perspective you know how old robert
kiyosaki is i want to say 78. he's 74 75
pull up his age i think he's probably
74. don't forget who's giving you this
advice this is a 74 year old man worth a
hundred million dollars probably he's a
rich he's 17 he's 74. he's a rich dad
okay
david who's just starting to out in his
career just starting to make money just
starting to save just learning what an
index fund is is is is is gang busters
on roi
everything that robert kearsky talks
about might not be applicable to you or
our friends at home if our friends are
just kind of getting going they're like
look i'm trying to save i'm trying to
invest i'm trying to get a 401k maybe
i'm gonna invest in a little bitcoin
you're not exactly on robert kiyosaki's
level there's levels to this game
if he if there's levels you know zero
you've got no money level one you're
starting to make a little money number
two you're you know he's on level five
right maybe i'm on level three or four
right now i'm not on the kiyosaki level
pbd level level five but i'm doing all
right i'm probably on level four right
but not all advice is
applicable to everyone so if you're
young
and you're investing for the long term
and you don't think the world is coming
to an end
when people talk about a stock market
crash and the world is coming to an end
honestly tune out the noise that's
something that i'm very a very big
proponent of look i've lived through
three different stock market crashes
right now
2 000 the dot-com bubble 2008
right when i started investing 2007 2008
which was the great recession right and
now 2020 with kovid
and the stock market is at an all-time
high bro
so what am i saying here is that there's
always going to be people basically
saying stock market crash
now's the time world's coming to an end
who knows what's happening but every
single time
six months later a year later a couple
years later the market is at all-time
high
so understand that the market recovers
faster
nowadays than it did back then is that a
thing no i i mean
dude the stock market crashed well
listen to 2 000
and six months later was at an all-time
high gotcha and even the covid thing
like the covet crash is just because
people you know that's like a temporary
thing as soon as
kovid was gone and i say that very
lightly because there's never a lot of
air quotes going on yeah cause that's
like you know when people are more
vaccinated there are more things being
opened up then that thing was bound to
just skyrocket back up
so listen here's what i'll tell you is
this
and there needs to be two things on your
mind there's a difference between saving
and investing now you might say what's
the difference says one is short-term
one is long-term saving is for the next
one to three years for sure that's
saving money do not put any of that
money in the market investing is long
term minimum
five years in my opinion okay ten years
retirement fifty years down the line
one is risk
one is safety and security understand
the difference you feel me
so if someone says there's a stock
market crash and you're 25 years old
you're 35 years old bro you got time
especially if it's your 401k or a roth
ira that's money you're not going to be
touching for another 30 plus years
now the reason you keep your money in
cash
or savings is so you don't have to worry
about a stock market crash there's a
crash you keep cash on hand and then you
maybe buy some distressed assets buy the
dip whatever you want to call it but if
you're young
you should be looking forward
to
a crash because that means all right
cool that's an opportunity to buy more
okay understand the difference between
saving investing so what's my point with
here this crash didn't happen
kiyosaki got it wrong
he usually gets it right
but
if he's just allowed to be wrong and
then nobody says anything
what's going to stop him from just
making more ridiculous salacious
opinions right prophecies yeah
we'd love to hear kiyosaki's opinion on
this i'm sure he's out there spinning
this again i respect kiyosaki i don't
this is not being disrespectful to
kiyosaki that's like saying lebron is
probably the second best basketball
player of all time if he's got a shitty
game and he goes two for 20 i'm gonna
say bro you had a horrible game right i
know you're i know you're the goat i
know you're amazing you know tom brady
in my opinion best football player of
all time he threw a pick six to lose the
game last week hey bro you messed up so
that's where i'm at with kiyosaki are
you the goat are you the goat of
personal finance yeah are you worth 100
million dollars are you a rich dad hell
yeah you are bro
but you're wrong on this you had a bad
game he had a bad game
and it's out in the it's out in the open
it's out in the public so anyway in the
fourth quarter he had a bad fourth
quarter he did have a bad fourth quarter
anyway i hope the stock market keeps
trending upwards i hope you guys are
saving that money so you can invest save
that money so you can invest that's a
big deal and listen tune out the noise i
think that is basically what i'm saying
i think if there's if there's something
that i can put a button on this entire
conversation a little ribbon a nice
little uh
mexican ribbon for your pinata look that
you got going on over there david sick
look
is that you need to turn out the noise
tune it out there's going to be people
telling there's crashes there's going to
be telling you that bitcoin's going to a
billion there's going to be people that
are telling you that bitcoin's going to
zero it's going to be telling you that
crypto ain't [ __ ] there's going to be
people saying that the real estate
market is going up it's going down
there's going to be a million opinions
actually technically 8 billion opinion
opinions but you know they say that
opinions are like [ __ ] everyone has
one
and they usually smell david
okay favorite it's one of my favorite
lines
and there it is david i am heated i am
fired up i noticed but because i care
because i care what about you david
weigh in on this before we move on yeah
again i still stand with
look like you said he's the goat
he's the goat every goat has a bad game
he's gonna make another prediction he
might be right he might be wrong might
be have another two bad games in a row
okay though in this case it's like all
right buddy you got one more she got one
more robert after that anyway it was
pretty interesting because when i shook
his hand took a picture said what's up
spent some time with him he spun it and
he said look man there's gonna i was
talking about the bond market
well you you specifically said stock
market here did i say stock i'm unboxing
i meant i meant bot okay nice pin job
we'll give you a pass this time mr
kiyosaki kimo sabe
however
don't let it happen again don't let it
happen anyway
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
size cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken